-It is time for
"Wheel of Freestyle"!
-♪ Tonight Show
Wheel of Freestyle ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Joining me right now
is our very own Tariq Trotter
from The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq will be facing off
against a worthy opponent.
His new movie,
"Tick, Tick... Boom!"
is in theaters now and streaming
on Netflix this Friday.
You could see
Freestyle Love Supreme
on Broadway
at the Booth Theatre.
Please welcome
Lin-Manuel Miranda!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
Yo!
Come on!
Come on, buddy!
-Hello, everybody.
-Yeah!
That is exactly right.
That is exactly right!
Yes!
-Oh!
-Welcome!
We love you.
They love you.
Here's how this works.
On your turn,
you're gonna
hit this button here, okay?
It will activate
a random word generator.
It'll land
on three random words,
then it's your job to work
those words into a freestyle --
a freestyle rap.
Sound good?
-Okay.
-Okay, all right.
Lin, you're our guest,
so please hit
the generator button,
and you'll go first.
-I've had this anxiety dream
so many times.
No whammies!
[ Beeping ]
-No whammies.
[ Laughter ]
-NFT, "Taylor's Version,"
Build Back Better.
-Sure.
-I'm not making it easy for you.
All right, NFT,
"Taylor's Version,"
Build Back Better.
-Okay.
-Lin.
Roots, can we get a beat?
♪♪
-♪ I'm not nervous,
but I took some ecstasy ♪
♪ I'mma sell it one time
as an NFT ♪
♪ Yeah, then I'll freestyle
and kill 'em all ♪
♪ Just like "Taylor's Version"
did to Jake Gyllenhaal ♪
♪ Oh, in my real black sweater ♪
♪ I'll give you a $1,000,
you can build back better ♪
Oh! Come on! Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yo!
Oh, my God!
Yes!
-I'm sorry, Jake, I love you.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-All right, that was amazing.
Tariq, let's see
if you can beat that.
When you're ready,
hit the button, bud.
-Big, big money.
[ Laughter ]
[ Beeping ]
-Jell-O --
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
-Oh, my God.
-Who would do that to you, dude?
That's the writers
messing with you, dude.
-Yeah.
-Jell-O shots,
Spider-Man, Rumpelstiltskin.
Rumpelstiltskin.
[ Laughter ]
That's the --
I've never heard --
That's tough.
-I've heard of Rumpelstiltskin.
-Yeah, I've heard of him,
but I've never heard
in a rap before.
All right, here we go.
Jell-O shots --
-Okay.
-Spider-Man, Rumpelstiltskin.
Roots, can we get a beat?
♪♪
-♪ Should I be mellow
or mellow not ♪
♪ Because, Lin, you came out
like, hello, hot ♪
♪ I'm trying to understand
the energy this fellow's got ♪
♪ Must have been the alcohol
inside those Jell-O shots ♪
♪ Look, call your
insurance provider, man ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm
the neighborhood hero ♪
♪ Not Spider-Man ♪
♪ And we still friends, but
y'all all know who still wins ♪
♪ This is leader run anew,
this is Rumpelstiltskin's ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo! Come on!
Yo!
How?!
-You monster.
-How?!
How in the world?!
How?!
-Whoo!
-Oh, I loved that.
That was great.
Now, look, we're gonna end this
now with the final round.
You'll each be getting
the same words,
and you're gonna take turns
doing verses with the same beat.
Okay?
Gentlemen, when you're ready.
I'm gonna hit this button.
[ Beeping ]
Big, big, big money.
Leaf peeping...
[ Light laughter ]
That's where
you look at leaves, yeah.
Memory foam.
"Tick, Tick... Boom!"
-Hey!
-Yeah, leaf peeping,
memory foam...
-And "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
-...and "Tick, Tick... Boom,"
yep.
-So, like, I'll do --
I'll round leaf peeping,
and then,
you'll round leaf peeping --
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
-Yeah, we'll do -- okay.
-Or you should go first, though.
-Whatever you want.
-Yeah.
-You're one of
the greatest rappers alive.
-No, no, you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Literally, whatever you want.
-Exactly.
Yeah, no joke.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, Lin.
Roots, whenever you're ready.
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ This is the collabo,
keep creeping ♪
♪ Every autumn,
we got 'em, we leaf peeping ♪
-♪ I keep creeping Tariq,
I keep teaching ♪
♪ So these fools know
that I'mma keep reaching ♪
-♪ You keep reaching,
and you never let him alone ♪
♪ They'll never forget you,
that [bleep] like memory foam ♪
-♪ Give me the throne
and let me alone ♪
♪ I remember it all,
my mic is memory foam ♪
♪ When I step into the party,
I stepped into the room ♪
♪ Yo, I think I heard something
go "Tick, Tick... Boom!" ♪
-♪ I stepped into the room,
and, yo, I can't believe ♪
♪ I'm in the sick,
sick room with you ♪
♪ Jesus, what are we gonna do ♪
♪ Freestyle Love Supreme
is on Broadway, too ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Word up.
-Yo, Tariq Trotter,
Lin-Manuel Miranda!
♪♪
That is how you do it
right there! Come on!